genießt deine Kinder und das war so mit
der weiße schwuchting den ich je gehört
habe und ich habe einfach so gesagt nein
ich möchte alt wäre
älter werden ich möchte auf Gymnasium
kommen ich möchte mein Abi machen und
ich möchte dann arbeiten und ich möchte
auch so cool sein und dann habe ich so
gedacht so oft als ich auf dem Gymnasium
war einer fünften Klasse und so dachte
ich so boah Alter voll heftig ich werde
dich arbeiten so chill ich mir nicht
aber junge das war die beste Zeit des
Lebens Grundschule ist die beste Zeit
die man je haben wird
Freunde was geht ab herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen Video diesmal ein kleines
oder etwas größeres commentary zusammen
mit dem concrafter und bei mir dann
zusammen mit Patrick hey heftig äh ein
Thema was wir gerne ansprechen möchten
das sieht ja wahrscheinlich auch schon
den Titel was es sich da handelt oder
wie demokratisch und wie nennt man das
eigentlich so intellektuelle
demokratisch
was komplett anderes gesagt einfach Rede
demokratisch okay und zwar möchten wir
über unsere Kindheit ein bisschen so
schwer so ein paar Vergleiche machen ja
ja und äh soll ich wieder anfangen ja
klar
okay und zwar als ich geboren
als ich
ja sagen wir mal so
in der ersten Klasse war da habe ich ja
im Kosovo im Kosovo gelebt und da hatten
wir zum Dorf haben wir dann halt habe so
ein Haus gehabt und so ein halt meine
Schule war halt 100 Meter von mir
entfernt das war halt relativ chillig
was das angeht aber um 5 Punkte kommen
ich hatte damals einfach gar nichts ich
hatte glaube ich so ein Stift und ein
Heft so egal auf jeden Fall war meine
Kindheit so ich war halt immer draußen
abgespielt immer immer immer ich hatte
damals diese Nintendo 36 meine mit dem
chillen Display Controller
Controller ne also schon nice und
ja damit habe ich doch schon irgendwie
nach Hausaufgaben und ich hatte damals
mein Bruder was mit Haus sogar fertig ne
und dann so hat er schon gespielt nein
ich muss jetzt irgend 20 Minuten die
muss ich ausnutzen und damit halt die
ganze Zeit raus gewesen und das war halt
auch als nach Deutschland gekommen bin
in der Grundschulzeit hier und in der
fünften und so weiter war es eigentlich
auch so dass ich halt nicht so mega viel
spielen durfte vor allem so heute ne
fragen Sie alle die Mutter ja Mama kann
ich eine halbe Stunde PC und damals
weißt du auf dem Sport das hat gefragt
ja da habe ich noch eine Stunde weil wir
hatten also relativ nah bei uns kann man
meine Mutter ja ab nach Hause und nicht
so bitte bitte darf ich noch eine halbe
Stunde draußen bleiben bitte bitte mich
auch gerade schon erzählt habe ob ich
jemand bei Skype an aber mich gerade
erzählt habe also auf dem Weg nach Hause
und da war so ein Dönerladen ne und dann
geht einfach so so so fünf klässler mit
seinem Kopfhörern ich denke so hörte
gerade so
oder so und was ist einfach so eine fünf
oder so könnte mein Sohn sein und hat er
so ein iPad
bei mir war es zum Beispiel damals so
also wie ich wohne halt auch jetzt nicht
so weit von der Schule weg und die
Eltern waren immer so als mein Vater hat
immer solche so zur Schule gegangen sind
mein Vater immer so stand zu einer Tür
zu geguckt ob wir zwei ankommen uns was
alles und es lief halt auch immer also
da weiß nicht ich finde irgendwie damals
waren die Eltern auch so ein bisschen
mehr so ja wir passt auf unsere Kinder
auf und ja sehr wichtig und ich fand das
auch eigentlich eigentlich war das auch
gut dass sie so regelmäßig die sich so
ich durfte zum Beispiel täglich eine
halbe Stunde Fernsehen eine halbe Stunde
zocken und wenn man um eine aus der
Schule rauskommt dann äh halt hat man
das halt eigentlich ich habe das sofort
ausgenutzt total dumm danach bin ich
dann immer so nach draußen gegangen habe
so Fußball gespielt oder verstecken oder
auf Sportplatz irgendwie gechillt oder
sowas und halt sowas alles gemacht oder
wer hat noch so kleine Pistolen so wo
man so komischen rein tun konnte und
sowas alles und dann haben oder so
Schoko Zigaretten und dann dachte
oh mein Gott
hat man dann halt Hausaufgaben immer so
auf Abends war schon was das war so mega
nice das Leben einfach man hat halt
einfach keine Sorgen weil so Grundschule
oder Kindergarten hat dann zu Hause
gechillt und hat halt nur gespielt und
so und mittlerweile ist es irgendwie so
also ich sehe das so dass ich war z.B
letztens bei uns in der Mensa und es war
ein Mädel die war so elf oder so drei
Käse hoch mit ihrem Freundinnen saßen
die da so so mega die übelst coolen so
mäßig ne jetzt nicht und dann saßen
wieder und jetzt den Freundinnen ja auf
Instagram letzten Bild gepostet sie war
so 11 saß also mit ihrem Samsung Galaxy
kommt so von da und da und das ist so
eine Stadt hier so von uns und 30
Kilometer
entfernen und sowas alles so ich habe
den dann bei Instagram message
angeschrieben und blabla und ich sehe
junge Mann ihr seid elf geht immer
spielen oder irgendwie sowas
11 gemacht
irgendwie mal eine Runde gegeneinander
gezogen sowas alles wir wünschen wenn
ihr so Denkmal Zuschauer wenn ihr
irgendwas seid ah die haben mir auch
gezockt ne erstens das war komplett an
wie weniger gespielt und zweiten
Highlight das war einfach so der du hast
so all die ganzen Tag so ausgenutzt und
jetzt gönn dir weißt du vor allem ist
mir aufgefallen ist die Eltern die die
meisten Eltern so die neue Generation
die kümmern sich halt so überhaupt nicht
um ihre Kinder so ja Mama kann ich Black
Ops 2 so ja lass mich in Ruhe und bei
uns war das so nein nein nein nein nein
ich musste so lange kämpfen dass ich
eine scheiß Konsole bekomme heftig dass
ich irgendwie eine PS2 bekommen oder so
boah PS2 habe ich zum Geburtstag
bekommen nachdem ich gebetet habe
bettelt oder so immer so ein einziger
Wunsch meine also play 3 mit Kameras
mega geil ich habe so gesuchtet oder
dieses PS2 mit dieser Kamera auch wo man
dann wenn man dann so Display stellen
muss hat sich dann selber im Fernsehen
gesehen und musste dann so rumschlagen
und sowas alles und so es war schon mega
geil das war schon vor allem kennst du
Blues clues ja klar
Fernseher und wir hatten noch deutsches
Fernsehen ne und äh habe ich auch so
bloß losgeguckt und immer so also damals
bin ich wirklich so am am freien Tagen
ne ich habe aber was um 8 Uhr
aufgestanden und habe bloß geguckt so
also
diese Bilder da reingegangen ist ne so
warum kann ich das nicht warum warum
der wollte was anfangen zu machen
hier
so jetzt brauchen wir ein Bastelkleber
und ich hatte nie diesen verfickten
Bastelkleber weil ich weiß nicht mehr
bekommen
und kennst ja mein pocket oder ja klar
ja jetzt
ich kann so Schule vier damals in der
Grundschule hat mir nur vier Stunden das
war Vergnügung pur ja Viertelstunde ich
renne zum Bus und wenn ich vier Stunden
hatte ich wäre einfach gerannt ich
wollte einfach das erste was halt bei
Quito kam war halt Pokémon das erste
davor glaube ich gab vielleicht mal was
aber das hat mich nicht interessiert
erst Pokémon und dann Digimon und dann
Yu-Gi-Oh das war einfach so heftig und
wenn man sechs Stunden hatte es war
einfach nur gerannt wie ein Bastard um
das nicht zu verpassen was bei dir
gerade angekommen Alter
so ein schöner
Erinnerungen an und ich habe wir haben
immer gefragt der kann mich ein bisschen
eher gehen so in der Schule und dann das
waren halt nur 200 m oder so und ich bin
dann gelaufen des Todes mit meinen
Freunden und dann haben wir Pokémon
geguckt und dann immer so zwei Folgen
oder zum Beispiel so habe ich zum
Yu-Gi-Oh kennengelernt es war so Winter
und es lief irgendwie eine abendfolge
von Pokémon oder irgend so ein Pokémon
Film war es glaube ich sogar die laufen
ja manchmal ja jährlich oder so und dann
oh die Filme waren 16 Uhr bei einem muss
nicht sogar weinen mit dem mit Pikachu
wo Pikachu fast gestorben wäre wegen Ash
und sowas schon lange her
jedenfalls zu Hause das war schon am
dämmern und mein Kumpel war so auch noch
da und ich sah ich darf eigentlich nur
immer so halbe Stunde aber wir haben
schon Film geguckt zwei Stunden ich darf
nicht so lang wenn Eltern mein Kumpel
sein komm wir gucken jetzt noch weiter
was hier noch so läuft meine Eltern also
nicht da und dann war halt kam Yu-Gi-Oh
so erste Folge oder so auf Pokito 2
damals und dann junge diese Disk und
alles für diese Karten hier hat man
dieses Ding so das schicken die Karten
rein und sowas
drei Karten gekauft hat weißer Drache
Pump drauf und dann habe ich vorgestellt
der ist jetzt hier der greift vielleicht
jeden Moment an
vor allem kennst du bei Pokémon wo dann
also Pikachu also echt so diesen Stein
zu Verwandlung hatten ne für Pikachu und
das ist dieser Donnerstein ist ja genau
und dann waren die pennen und dann geht
Pikachu raus so nachts auf so einer
Wiese und dann eskaliert
ist gerannt und ging so ein Stein die
ganze Zeit so hatte ich eskaliert ist ne
das war so traurig wieder so geredet
haben so ja ich weiß nicht wollte echt
dass er dass er sich verwandelt oder
eher nicht nee wollte nicht ja glaube
ich wollte das
Pikachu wollte auch nicht aber das war
so
traurig weil die wollten also so bleiben
und vor allem jetzt so in den Kommentare
schreibt ah aber er guckt ihr habt ja
auch Fernsehen guckt okay was läuft
heutzutage im Fernsehen im Vergleich
dazu Junge
im Fernsehen das ist nichts mehr
vielleicht zu damals natürlich werden
das muss man auch mal sagen die Leute
irgendwie die jetzt irgendwie weiß ich
nicht jetzt zur Zeit irgendwie 30 sind
oder sagen wir mal 27 oder so ich bin
jetzt ich bin jetzt 17 ich werde bald 18
wenn jetzt so Leute irgendwie 32 sind
oder so die sind dann genauso mein alter
so ca das Doppelte oder 34 oder so die
werden natürlich auch sagen unsere
Kindheit war viel besser wir haben nur
auf der Straße das hat jede Generation
ihr werdet auch später euren Kindern
sagen dass eure Kinder besser war aber
wir sind halt so die ersten Leute die so
richtig aktiv im Internet sind wir sind
also die ersten Generation das kann man
eigentlich so sagen die so richtig dass
du das Internet verbreiten weil jede
Generation mit ihm die sagen dass ihre
Generation besser war weil man das halt
die jetzige Zeit da kann man sich
irgendwie nicht so drin fest finden weil
unsere Sachen die für uns damals so mega
geil waren dies ist heute so Standard
und das hat sich alles verstanden das
ist nicht verstanden
Pokémon die erste Staffel zieht euch
einfach mal die erste Staffel rein
scheiß mal auf übelste 3D Grafik die da
vielleicht heute ist ich guck's nicht
mehr wenn da irgendwie so oder diese
neuen Spiele oder diese alten Spiele wo
die Story im Vordergrund stand das war
so hammer vor allem boah ja ich packe
schon mal in die Beschreibung so zehn
links mit Soundtracks und ja und
Yu-Gi-Oh und Pokémon und sowas alles so
ich bin ja ein der heftigsten Dragon
Ball Z Freaks ist auf diesem
verschissenen Planeten gibt ne und auch
bei Pokémon und überall ne ist ja so
dass diese Zeichnungen dieser neue
Zeichnungen ne ne die animierungen so
schlecht die sind so scheiße
ja guck mal ne ohne Witz ohne diese
scheiß Japan hätte ich keine Kindheit
gehabt ne ist so was guckt ihr denn
heute für eine Scheiße ja mein Sohn von
der Arbeit von der Schule mitten im
Leben Berlin Tag und Nacht da werden die
Kinder dort dramatisiert was sie geguckt
und das erfordert wird deine Fantasie
angeregt man fühlt sich einfach wenn du
so zum Beispiel Digimon habe ich sogar
die ganze Zeit gesungen ne Digimon das
ist ja voll gut gemacht von den äh Anime
Produzenten das als bei diesen ganzen
Serien ne ist der Reiz dass sie immer
was Neues entdecken und das kannst du
als Kind kannst du somit hineinschlüpfen
und das Hefti war immer wenn zwei Spiel
kann bei Pokémon oder so neue
Verwandlung Ja oder Nein Pokémon
oder bei Pokémon wollte man immer selber
so ein Pokedex haben und da wird dann so
angeregt und ich wollte immer selber
mein Pokedex haben so wo ich so kleine
Tiere die ich so sehe fotografieren und
dann so Pokedex und nachgucken was es so
für ein Tier ist aber es ging halt nicht
aber man war halt immer so Pokémon die
können das alles Blabla und er hat halt
so davon geträumt dass man auch sein
eigenes Pokémon hat so ein eigenes
Haustier oder sowas in Pokémon ist oder
sowas alles das war halt einfach die
Fantasie wird echt schon angeregt und
was heutzutage so im Fernsehen läuft
natürlich gibt's auch Super RTL und
Nickelodeon und auch noch RTL2 bei RTL2
läuft einfach nur Bullshit die ganze
Zeit
alter das ist so scheiße die hatten vor
kurzem lief Sonntag morgens Dragonball
Dragonball in der rote Pokémon und äh
noch was anderes und dann wurde das
abgeschafft und dann gibt es sollen die
auf der Ihre Homepage das weiterführen
aber ich habe bis jetzt noch nichts
davon gesehen
wie immer noch so dumm sein so eine
große zuschauerquelle einfach so weg
aber
ich wollte noch was sagen und zwar genau
bei Dragonball gab es ja so war das so
dass halt die halt heftig trainiert
haben auch von klein auf hat einfach so
Goku trainiert dann wollte ich halt
immer selber so einfach so damals oh ja
ich mache das Training einfach vom Herd
der Schildkröten bei Son Goku Krillin
und probiert das ob das bei mir wird und
ich wollte das immer schon trainieren ob
ich vielleicht so richtig über den
Menschen stark werden oder weiß halt
sehr viel kleiner und dann hatte ich
einfach so Fantasien so und dann waren
warst du auch klar im Kopf du warst
einfach nicht so psychisch belastet du
guckst aber mit dem Leben Alter wieso
Polizei oder so Randale macht da kommt
Gefängnis was passiert denn der Papa da
bist
Alter was läuft denn ich gucke guckst du
eigentlich nur Fernsehen ich gucke nicht
mehr viel Fernsehen nee also außer ab
und zu halt so habe ich letztens so von
den Sommerferien habe ich How I met your
mother
ja also diese Serien halten
schon für etwas ältere also jetzt noch
nicht wenn man so 11 12 ist so das
sollte man da sollte man Pokémon gucken
was läuft nicht im Fernsehen deswegen
gehen die Kinder mit iPads in der Schule
und spielen irgendwie oder sind auf
Facebook rum und vor ein paar passt auf
Leute mit diesen ganzen Computer scheiße
und so ich durfte allgemein nicht nur
aus Regelung früher nicht so viel
spielen soll ich hatte ähm also ich
klein war 2005 hatte ich epileptischen
Anfall weiß was das ist oder
dadurch dass das sagen soll also wurden
halt so ein bisschen meine Eltern so
oder so ein bisschen schon so heftig
traumatisiert ne das ist doof die ganzen
Jahre halt auch nie über 20 Minuten
gehen weil die halt Angst hatten dass
ich halt wieder sowas
erleiden werde ja mittlerweile ist das
schon lange weg aber sowas passt auf ihr
könnt davon kaputt gehen in die jungen
weil oder Gehirn ist noch nicht so
entwickelt und das ist nur
Entwicklungsprozess bei uns so an der
Grenze und wenn jetzt dann so richtig
eskaliert und richtig übertreibt ich
schwöre es euch nicht so dass ihr eure
Augen werden kaputt gehen das denkst du
du hast einfach mein Vater
ist einfach so
wie denkt googlet man einfach Epilepsie
was da ist das ist nicht lustig das
bekommen das nicht verarbeiten kann wenn
er übertreibt dann ist das nicht mehr
lustig ohne Witz oder es geht also ihr
guckt ja zurzeit alle also jetzt nicht
so krankheitsmäßig aber übertreibt es
einfach nicht und zwar ihr guckt ja
sagen wir mal die die das gerade gucken
die gucken ja unsere Let's Plays oder
unsere Videos halt auf Youtube was sie
an sich jetzt mal gut ist aber ähm ich
finde wenn man wirklich den ganzen Tag
davor und 10 Millionen Leute abonniert
hat auf Youtube und den ganzen Tag da
freuen und das guckt und das gucken und
das guckt das ist natürlich gut dass ihr
den Leuten Klicks gibt und sowas alles
ist da sage ich auch gar nichts gegen
aber ähm es wäre besser was hätte ja ach
so ich soll die soll nicht übertreiben
die soll nicht übertreiben so ich dachte
nein nein das ist halt so wenn ihr
Videos gucken ist fast das gleiche wie
zocken da kommen
dass sie sagt ich gucke jetzt nur das
Video von dem und dem und das war ich
mir eventuell dafür oft dass ich erstmal
irgendwie nach draußen gehe Spiel mit
meinen Freunden und wenn heute wenn es
heute Abend dunkel ist und kalt und ich
gegessen habe dann gucke ich mir das
das Video an und dann deine schön aber
wenn ihr dann irgendwie wenn ich das
sehe z.B selbst immer bei mir in der
Schule ich glaube die Schule und
unterhalten sich über Black Ops Alter so
12-jährige die unterhalten sich sogar um
18 ist oder auch Berlin
was [__] überhaupt ist und warum warum
versorgt man sich das so ja dafür können
eigentlich die Kinder auch nicht so mega
viel das ist einfach so die ganzen
Medien haben sich verschlechtert also
ist für ein Arsch die Eltern die sind
auch irgendwie bisschen kaputt
oder irgendwie sowas also nicht jede
Familie ist nicht so denken so jeder von
euch nein aber es ist bei einfach auch
alles erlauben und alles durchgehen und
das weiß ich nicht ich werde z.B mein
Kindern mein das erste was ich meine
Kinder machen werde ich werde ihn von
meiner Kindheit erzählen und den die
Serien zeigen auf jeden Fall machen
wenn ich ein bisschen Geld mir
zusammengespart habe und also nichts
brauchst du dies das ich hoffe perfekt
alle behinderten Anime Serien
irgendwann werde ich wie pada habe alle
kaufe ich mir Lager ich mit ihm weil ich
Kinder habe das werdet ihr jetzt gucken
von Pokémon One Piece Dragonball alles
werdet ihr das gucken wenn das so was
weiß ich was in 10 Jahren für eine
scheiße läuft ne ich weiß man weiß nicht
was in 10 Jahren ist aber in 10 Jahren
wird so sein dass die Leute die jetzt
über die wir gerade lässt dann werden
die über die lästern jetzt dran sind
weil noch was heute noch ist wird
bestimmt besser sein als das in 10
Jahren wird das so sein ihr habt
bestimmt so ein Flatscreen das ist
bestimmt somit da sieht man nicht mehr
der Bildschirm weil das ist so wie nennt
man das ähm was meinst Du ja das ist
eine technische smartwatches geben dass
in eine Uhr hat womit ihr dann im
Unterricht doch spicken könnt und alles
möglich und da muss man man kriegt
vielleicht auch so ein Chip in sein ihr
werdet ja es ist einfach
so braucht man keine Menschen mehr also
und ja das werde ich dann meinen Kindern
zeigen und ich wäre dann so meine Kinder
sagen ja aber bei Floyd der guck ja ihr
guckt mir jeden Tag und Nacht warum darf
ich eigentlich gucken guck Dragon Ball
und das
habe ich bringe den um Alter die werden
auch Dragonball gucken ich lade deine
Freunde wir gucken alle zusammen ich
werde mit meinen Kindern zusammen
oder so nicht gefällt da gibt's ja
natürlich Leute den Dragonball damals
nicht gefallen hat gibt's sehr wenige
Jungs aber wenn sie nicht gefällt dann
ist es ja gut aber dann soll was anderes
mittlerweile kann Ihnen das gar nicht
gefallen weil sie nicht mehr läuft im
Fernsehen die kennen ja nur sowas wie
Berlin Tag und Nacht oder mitten im
Leben oder auch sowas wie wie Spongebob
was natürlich auch noch witzig ist aber
die neuen Folgen sind auch einfach nur
scheiße und verdammt also das ist
einfach diese ganzen neue scheiße ist
einfach aber du kennst du ne klar und
der macht ja sein äh Tracks immer so ein
bisschen so kam mir mehr so ein bisschen
Anspielungen und so ne mit der ist ja so
ist ja ein bisschen älter als wir bei
uns ist es so wo wo Dragonball richtig
früher läuft also richtig früher da
waren wir so in der dritten Klasse ne
das habe ich zwar ab und zu gucken aber
ich habe es nicht bekomme das Story
deshalb wo das er abgesetzt wegen oder
gekettet haben Gewalt dies das und da
habe ich das ja vor vier Jahren im
Internet nach also nachgeschaut also
dass ich das mal wieder angeguckt habe
die Generation also hier fünf Jahre die
haben damals okay One Piece lief ja
damals von 1980 das kennt einfach keiner
ich habe mal letztens in meiner
jagerstufe ich meine ein bisschen älter
als die weil ich von der Realschule
komme und dann habe ich einfach gefragt
jo kennst du überhaupt Dragonball der so
nur was ist das ich meine jeder kennt
doch mal ein Kamehameha hat doch schon
mal jemand gehört also nö Pokémon hast
du schon mal geguckt was was junge nein
ich laber keinen Scheiß ich dachte ich
stehe vor einer Statue was laberst du da
hast du noch nie gesehen der so die über
die überhaupt nicht ne
gar nichts okay eine Serie
eine Serie so was hast du eigentlich
eine Kinder gemacht
hat aber so
24/7 so ein 30 so ganze gezeigt haben
aber wir reden jetzt nur über die Spiele
es gibt ja noch andere Sachen und zwar
allein die Kleidung auch schon ne wir
hatten damals die Sachen an wo man mit
dreckig werden konnte
oder wir laufen so dich in Mathe und die
Hose ist dreckig und dann wird die Hose
ist gerissen damit da so ein Flicker
drauf genäht mittlerweile laufen die da
Grundschule mit Air Max rum und den
ganzen Scheiß
und die trinken so Sachen wie Monster
Energy junge diese diese die Leute die
dann fünf oder sechste Klasse gehen
Alter trink mal was vernünftiges Alter
oh mein Gott
damals oh mein Gott dürfen wir das
überhaupt trinken [__]
wir werden erwischt Mann nein lass doch
nicht machen oder so ja die Ziele sind
einfach
Instagram 5 Klasse heute eingeschult
wurde den Realschule
die Dreiecke machen so diese bitchigen
[__] Mädels alle diese Fotos aus
wie 20 ist
und holen sich 30 drauf gerade ihren
ersten Menstruationszyklus gehabt
ich schwöre ich habe mir ich war so Club
gegessen
aussieht mein Freund sein
es ist halt wirklich so vor allem das
beste Spiel war halt immer krass von der
Schule nachdem du den ganzen das ganze
Programm fertig hatte und schön mit mit
Sachen wie weißt du diese Serien haben
einfach so Freundschaft alles verbunden
Kollege ruf mich einfach so klingeln
nein er ruft mich so von draußen
komm raus verstecken fahren
Bionicle zusammengebaut andere
neben uns gezogen ist und das Grundstück
kommt so ruft so hey die Jungs kann ich
habe auch eine ganze ja klar komm mit
dann haben wir so gezockt und
mittlerweile erst zu Instagram
kennenlernen so in der Message Facebook
schreiben und Bilder austauschen dann
ein bisschen snapchat da trifft man sich
so dann redet man vielleicht nur so ganz
klein bisschen und das damals einfach
nur du machst auch Fußball ich auch lass
zocken das beste Freunde sein so bion
weißt du wo man so kombinieren konnte
zwei kostenlose Superding machen
Weihnachtsgeschenke immer so bionicles
oder Lego oder irgendwie weiß ich nicht
dann dann mal viel fifa 06 oder
irgendwie sowas und dann habe ich immer
noch das habe ich immer noch vier ging
es bei mir los Alter bei mir ging halt
zehnjähriges Jahr
schon Dämmerung aber verstecken fangen
am besten Resultate
oder man wurde erkannt wenn man so ein
bisschen lauter geatmet hat und sowas
alles sofort
Mama wir spielen noch in 15 Minuten dann
kommen
mega geil Alter
ach ja ja Kindheit war schon mega geil
bei uns heutzutage ist einfach nur Weise
vor allem wenn ihr so sagt oh cool mal
cool ich höre Auto oh jo Alter
haben wir auch gesagt jeder aber lasst
euch mal wirklich spritzt es euch euer
Herz rein nein
du lebst ja nur einmal dann kannst du
nicht mehr so zurückgehen und noch mal
dass man mal wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel
bis 20 jo ich möchte mit Kollegen
Verstecken spielen ne das Spiel zu
verstecken
und deine Kollegen auch aber das kannst
Du sowieso das passt
nicht mehr so diese ganzen Fantasien die
man damals hatte dass man irgendwie so
eins mit der Natur ist und Puppen und
das so durch die Wälder schleicht und
alles vor allem heutzutage weiß ich
nicht also wir wissen natürlich dass sie
das alles kennt und ich denke viele
Leute die gerade so in der Phase sind
die kennen das bzw sehen sich daran
selbst wieder oder beleidigen uns jetzt
oder geben den Daumen runter oder alles
aber es ist halt einfach so dass wir wir
finden also wir finden das einfach nur
komisch wie sich das alles verändert hat
bzw jetzt muss ich auch irgendwas
verändern aber es wäre einfach cooler
wenn irgendwie alles so geblieben wäre
und ich wäre so gerne wieder ein Kind
obwohl ich eigentlich noch in der Jugend
bin aber mein Vater hat mir damals
gesagt genießt deine Kinder und das war
so mit der weiße [__] den ich je
gehört habe und ich habe einfach so
gesagt nein ich möchte alt wäre
älter werden ich möchte auf Gymnasium
kommen ich möchte mein Abi machen und
ich möchte dann arbeiten und ich möchte
auch so cool sein und dann habe ich so
gedacht so oft als ich auf dem Gymnasium
war einer fünften Klasse und so dachte
ich so boah Alter voll heftig ich werde
dich arbeiten sonst hätte ich mir nicht
aber junge das war die beste Zeit des
Lebens Grundschule ist die beste Zeit
die man je haben wird das ist einfach
nur Mann Mann genießt das einfach wenn
das irgendwie aus der Grundschule guckt
oder wenn ihr irgendwelche Geschwister
Grundschule sind sag den geht raus geht
spielen mit euren Freunden macht so viel
wir können damals habt ihr später habt
ihr dafür einfach keine Zeit mehr oder
kein kein Dings mehr keine Gelegenheit
Luka ist der Geld oder was
nicht eure Kindheit
Kindheit es ist einfach so genießt eure
Kinder das muss man einfach so sagen ich
schwöre
schreibt in die Kommentar genießt eure
Kindheit schreibt
Alter 12 nein wollt ihr dass wir also
das war's jetzt so mehr oder weniger
wenn wir uns unsere ganzen Sachen gesagt
natürlich
wieder so 10 Millionen Sachen nein ja
wollt ihr eventuell dass wir normal so
ein bisschen mehr reden da drüber so was
ich so verändert hat wie wir das so
finden so Patricks und Connys Meinung
oder irgendwie sowas und dann schreibt
uns in die Komments oder was ihr so
davon haltet von den ganzen
Veränderungen weil die meisten Zuschauer
sind einfach 14 und 13 und die sind
genauso die Gruppe wir sprechen zwar
vielleicht noch ein bisschen jünger sind
aber vielleicht könnt ihr das ja so auch
von euch so sagen wie sie das bei euch
so ist vielleicht haben wir das auch
alles ein bisschen falsch dargestellt
schreibt uns das einfach und gebt einen
Daumen Hoch wenn ihr genauso denkt und
dann würde ich sagen von mir erstmal
tschüss
ihr wisst Bescheid geht raus und spielen
und ich würde sagen haut rein bis zum
nächsten mal euer Patrick und da Ciao